Hi, Steve Kaufmann here.
And today I want to talk about
a subject that often comes up.
What is the easiest language to learn?
Okay.
Before I get into that, if you enjoy
these videos, please subscribe,
click on the bell for notifications.
If you follow me on a podcast,
uh, please leave a review.
So is there an easier language?
I think here there are both, um,
subjective factors and objective
factors, which you have to consider.
All right.
So I think the most important
consideration is how motivated are you
to learn the language, uh, because if you
are very motivated, the, the difficulties,
the objective difficulties, which
I'll get into, will kind of disappear.
So when it comes to which language is
easiest, you have to begin by saying which
language am I most motivated to learn?
All right.
A second consideration: to what extent
is it easy to find interesting material,
compelling input in that language?
Uh, I have to confess that I have had
difficulty with some languages where it
has been difficult to find compelling
input, Korean, Czech in some ways, uh,
whereas other languages where there's
lots of content available on the
internet, especially today, uh, like
Russian and like Spanish, like English.
It's a lot easier.
Uh, I'm struggling a bit
now with Arabic and Persian.
I have recently found some
really good stuff in Arabic.
Um, once I get ahold of some compelling
content, it spurs me on, it influences
my, my confidence, my enthusiasm.
So, um, obviously a subjective factor then
is how interested are you in the language?
Uh, can you find compelling
input in  that language?
Another thing  is confident levels...
confidence level.
If you sort of think you can't or
whatever, if you're, so you're not
interested or you can't find interesting
content and you think you can't learn it,
it's going to be very difficult for you.
Whereas if you are convinced
that you can do it, this is
another subjective consideration
that I think is very important.
And, uh, it, as in any language
learning situation, you
have to take the initiative.
You have to take the initiative to go out
there and find content of interest and
pursue things that are of interest to you.
So those are some of the subjective
considerations, but there is one
factor that's kind of a combination
of subjective and objective.
So rather than saying language X is
the most difficult or the easiest
to a large extent, it depends on
the languages you already know.
So, because to me, vocabulary
is the biggest issue.
Language learning is about learning words.
So if you speak a language, say you speak
Spanish and you want to learn Italian,
obviously 85% of the words in Italian
are identifiable as being similar to
Spanish, even allowing for the odd false
friend, which really doesn't matter.
There aren't so many of them.
The fact that the vocabulary is similar
is going to help you, uh, similarly for
an English speaker, Spanish, French, all
of the Latin based languages have a lot
of vocabulary in common with English.
So I think the vocabulary
is the biggest issue.
It's a bigger issue,
I think, than grammar.
Because we can get used to the grammar
in time, we'll get used to the grammar,
but if we have to learn and relearn
and forget and relearn, and, and
there's so many words to learn that
makes the language more difficult.
For example, Romanian has a grammatical
structure that's quite unique.
They have a number of unique features.
However, 70% of their vocabulary is
very similar to other romance languages.
And so with that, Romanian becomes
quite easy to learn despite its
different grammatical structure.
So is the vocabulary in the
language you want to learn similar
to a language you already know?
So that means that for
example, for a person who...
so say a Japanese speaker.
They've got the characters in Japanese
and they've got a lot of the vocabulary.
Even the Koreans who don't use
Chinese characters, a lot of their
vocabulary, 50% just as the case with
the Japanese is of Chinese origin.
So they have an easier time, whereas
say Europeans or people from north
America or from the Middle East,
or from somewhere else where they
don't have this vocabulary, it's
going to be more difficult for them.
Now, objective consideration is
things like the writing system.
Obviously, if it's, it it's much
easier to learn a language that's
written in your own writing system,
because since you were a child you've
been reading in that writing system.
So to get the brain, even if you
understand how Chinese characters
work or Arabic writing, uh, it's
going to be difficult to get used
to reading, uh, comfortably quickly.
So that...
since reading is such a big part of
language learning, if you can't read
comfortably, it's going to slow you down.
So that's an objective consideration.
Now of the different writing systems,
some of them are very much parallel
to the Latin alphabet and that's the
case with Cyrillic or with Greek,
others are true alphabets, like
the Hangul, but very different.
And then you have syllabary is like
Japanese hiragana and Katakana.
And then you have, uh, I should
point out by the way, the Arabic
script is also an alphabet, but it's
for me, difficult to get used to.
Um, and then you have Chinese characters,
which are even more difficult.
So writing system is a big consideration.
Another, um, objective
consideration is grammar.
I find that of the languages that I
have learned, the Slavic languages
have the most complicated grammar,
more case endings to try to remember
while you're speaking, uh, certain
concepts like, uh, aspects of
verbs, verbs of motion that I found.
But I have never had to struggle
with issues in English like articles.
So maybe for speakers of those
other languages, the articles
in English, and maybe some other
things, make English difficult.
So it again gets back to this
idea that certain languages are
subjectively easier or difficult.
I know that the Foreign Service
Institute in the United States has
put, you know, their evaluation of
how many instructional hours are
required for different languages.
And on that basis, they rated
them by level of difficulty.
But that's typically based on an
English speaker in a classroom.
So how relevant that is to anybody
out there who doesn't happen to be
an English speaker studying in a
classroom I don't know, but it's also
a bit of an indicator of the level
of difficulty of different languages.
So easiest to learn, I would say
for an English speaker is Spanish.
Um, German is somewhat more complicated
in its grammar and I haven't done a
study, but I have the feeling that the
vocabulary between English and Spanish
is more similar than English and German.
Although there's a lot of
vocabulary in German that helps us.
I don't think either of those languages
is nearly as difficult as languages where
we have no common vocabulary: Arabic,
Persian or, uh, obviously Chinese.
So I hope that's helpful.
And a little bit of a discussion on
the difficulty of different languages.
And I'll leave you the couple of
videos I've done on the same subject.